ก็
สวัสดีค่ะ
คุณสวัสดีค่าผู้หญิงครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
วันนี้ก็เกิดมาเจอกับครูฟ้าและผู้หญิงใน
วีดีโอดีกินเนอะ
ครูฟังนะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์
ค่ะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
25 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอะไรคะมีผช
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022
อ่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้
วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 24
เดือน
กรกฎาคม
ปีพตต
ปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 อ่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
26 เดือน
เดือน
กรกฎาคมปีพตอีพตต
2565 ปีค.ศตเมื่อปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา 11:00 น 11 โมงกี่นาที
11 นาทีค่ะ 11  11
11  11 นาที
ดีมากค่ะครูฟ้าคะค่ะครูฟ้าชอบดื่มชาไหมคะ
นิสัยใบบริษัทเนี่ยผู้หญิง
ดื่มชาหรอผู้พาชอบหนึ่ง
ได้ไหม
ดำ
อ้าวมวยช่องดื่ม
กุมภาชอบดื่มชาว่าไงคะชายคณิน
ใช่ชานมไข่มุกค่ะหวี่เหมือนกันกูก็ทาไข่
มุกกันรออยู่บนนั้นอย่างนั้นเลยเหรอคะ
วะลืมนะที่ชานมไข่มุกนั้นมีไม่เอา
ไม่เอาชานมไข่มุกลบ
ๆประชาแบบนี้หรอนายค่ะชาแบบนี้เนี่ยชา
ร้อนชาแบบไอ Gray
Thai  English  xxx  English  Breakfast
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยชาอังกฤษ
ลิง
ทวินนี่
สายทไวนิ่งหรือทวินนิ่งช้าๆแต่มันจะมีซอง
เอา
ซองอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็จะมีเชื่อเชื่อเป็น
ยังไงก็ไม่รู้ว่าก็มีอันเนี้ยแล้วข้างใน
ก็จะมีชานี้ดูดีนะคะใช่ไหมรักคู่ฟ้าเนี่ย
ก็เอาชาเนี่ยใส่ลงไปในนี้ซาเล็กหน่อยไหม
แต่ใส่ลงไป
แล้วก็เทน้ำร้อนสาธา
ก็
เพราะว่าเราพูดถึงช้าชาเนี่ยชาระบบว่า
เป็นชาอังกฤษส่งไหมคะ
ประเทศอังกฤษเนี่ยเขาก็จะแบบอาจจะมีการ
ดื่มชาชาที่เป็นชากับ Afternoon  Tea
หรืออาจจะพูดว่าแบบ High  Tea อย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงจะให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูรูปแต่
ว่าอย่าเพิ่งดูแล้วกันนะคะแต่ว่าผู้หญิง
จะถามครูฟ้าว่าถ้าสมมติว่า
ฟ้าเนี่ยได้ไปดื่มช้ากับ
ผู้หญิงกว่านี้ค่ะ
ครูบี Spade ควีนอลิซาเบธที่ 2 น่ารักของ
อังกฤษสมัยอังกฤษเนี่ยก็จะมีคุยอีน
เนื้อ
หาพระสมมติว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยได้ไปดื่มชาใช่
ไหมกับวันนี้นะคะคุยนะฤทธิ์สวทได้แต่ว่า
ต้องเป็นชาแบบนี้นะเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงแชร์ให้
ดูต้อง Stop แชร์นี้ก่อน
ชาแบบไหนว่าคุยรารีเสด็จก็ต้องมีชาใช่ไหม
Sin  Sin  Sin สามัญจะต้องเป็นชาที่แบบ
ว่า
สักครู่นะคะได้หักผู้หญิงผู้ให้เวลาผู้
หญิง 1
2  3 ไปเย็นๆสิคะมาแล้วเห็นไหมคะฟ้าไง
โอ้ยบ่นี่ไง
ใช่ไหมอย่างนี้เราเรียกว่าอาฟเตอร์นูนที
หรือว่า High  Tea ใช่ไหมคะเป็นชาวก็จะมี
ชาร้อนชาร้อนจะไม่มีการอาซาเราก็จะมีชั้น
เนี่ยเราจะมีขนมมีสักคน
แล้วก็มีอะไรเนี่ยพวกแซนด์วิชนับเป็น
แซนด์วิชนะคะผู้หญิงคิดว่าเขาจะกินสัตว์
อันนี้ 1  2 แล้วก็ 3 มั้งไม่รู้นะคะถ้า
เขามาเนี่ย
วิธีกินนั่งใครใช่ๆๆกิ่งก็ไม่รู้นะคะว่า
กินยังไงเอามันเป็นให้คลาสไงคงฟ้าไฮโซถ้า
คุณฟ้าอ่าตรงนี้นะคะก็คือควีนใช่ไหมคะคุย
ลิซาเบ็ธ
แล้วก็ครูฟ้าอันนี้ก็จะเป็นครูฟ้าเนาะถ้า
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยได้ไปดื่มน้ำชาชากับควีน
เอลิซาเบธ
ฟ้าเนี่ยจะไปไหน
ไปฟรีเพราะว่าคุณป้าเออกูป่าแม่อยากไปดึง
ชานะคะแล้วก็มีเค้ก K ก็อยากกินเค้ก
ได้อยากเจอคุยลิซาเบ็ธแล้วคะ
แม่กินเค้ก
ได้ต้องไปอยู่แล้วค่ะไปแต่งตัวสวยๆใช่ไหม
ไม่มีแฟชั่นสวยๆสีฟ้าจะแต่งตัวสวยๆแล้ว
ครูฟ้าจะแต่งตัวยังไงอ่ะใส่ชุดอะไรเขาขอ
โทรศัพท์ผู้หญิงก็ให้กูมาร์แซย์สกรีนได้
หา Share  screen มาได้เปิดก่อนนะจริง
เนี่ยกูฟ้าได้มีชุดมาแล้ว
ป่าเนี่ยจะแต่งตัว
แบบนี้ฮะใส่เสียงอะไรคะ
อย่างเห็น
กดแชร์
นี่หาพี่
ไหนๆ
โอ๊ย
Google ฟ้ารูปการ์ดชุดกระโปรงยาเอาแล้ว
ก็
ก็โปร่งเนี่ยเกย์นี่เลยเหรอคะ
oem หานักเรียนคนไหนเนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าอะไร
นี้
โอ๊ตจะเขียนผิดอีกนะมีแค่บอกว่างงอันนี้
เป็นแบรนด์ใช่มั้ยใช่แฟนก็อยากใส่ชุด
โคเอ็มค่อยก็ใส่ชุดนี้ไปเมื่อจะมีเมคอัพ
ใช่ไหมแบบมีเมคอัพทำส่งมันจะหน้าตาแบบนี้
เลย
แต่พี่หายพี่ไม่ใช่ครูฟ้านะคะนักเรียน
รู้
เปิด
ให้ป๊าแต่ก็ใส่ชุดนี้ไปแล้วก็
เอาไปดื่มชาใช่มั้ยไปดื่มน้ำชาดูว่าไปจิก
พี่ชากับควีนอลิซาเบธนะคะแล้ว
ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
มีคำถาม
ขอได้ไปเจอคุยนาลิซาเบ็ธใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ทุก
คนเนี่ยจะได้เจอเจอกับคุยนาริตะเบ็ดครู
ฟ้าถ้าได้เจอแล้วก็ไปดื่มน้ำชาจะคุยนริศ
เสด็จเนี่ยครูฟ้า
คิดอยากถามอะไรควีนอลิซาเบธ
อย่าถามอะไรว่าต้องมีไปเช่นม้ากับควีนฉาบ
ถาม
ฮะถามได้หรอพี่ขนมได้อัดถ้าไม่ถามถ้ากู
ฟ้าแบบอาจจะไม่ได้อยากถามครูฟ้าอยากคุย
คุยอะไรกับคุยลิซาเบ็ธถ้าได้ไปเจอได้ไป
ดื่มน้ำชา
แต่กูว่ามีคำถามมหาคำถามมันจะมีคำถามเยอะ
มากทำให้กี่ข้อเอาผู้หญิงแล้วแต่ไฟฟ้าเลย
ค่ะครูฟ้าอยากถาม 100 ข้อก็ถามได้ค่ะ
ไม่อยากถามปีนาลิซาเบทนะคะว่า
ประกาศกูว่าอยู่ไหนคะอยู่นี่ไม่รู้ค่ะ
เพราะใจเย็นๆนะคะใส่ชุดสวยมากชุดสวยมาก
หอยของ groupon อ่ะข้อที่ 1 ก็คือว่าจะ
ถาม V นริศเซอร์วิสว่า
ค่ะฟรีฟิล์ม
กลุ่มมาก
คุยนาลิซาบิส
ถ้า
ไม่มีหนี้หากผู้หญิงคุยนะหรือ suite นะคะ
ดาบ
หักวีนาลิซาเบทเลือกได้
ระหว่างนี่เงินคุยก็จะมีช้อยส์เหมือนกัน
นะคำถามพี่ฟ้า
มีเงิน 1 ล้านล้านล้านล้านล้านรัฐๆ
โห
เงินเยอะมาก
พอแล้วพอแล้ว
ดอลล่าด้วยก็ได้อ่ะ
คิดว่าควีนมีนะคะมากนะคะถ้าควีนเอนะควีน
มีเงิน 1 ล้าน
ละลายดอลลาร์นะ
แต่ควีนเนี่ยจะต้องอยู่คนเดียวอ่ะถ้าไม่
มีเพื่อน
ไม่มีเพื่อน
ไม่มีใครเลยอยู่คนเดียว
เป็นควีนอยู่คนเดียวค่ะบี
ควีนเนี่ยมีเงิน 1
หนา
แต่ว่าควีนมีเพื่อน
โอเค
เพื่อน
เพื่อนคุณ 100 คนไปเลย
ควีนจะเลือกอะไร
โอคุมาฟ้าก็คือถ้าคุณฟ้าได้ไม่เจอคุยคู่
ฟ้าก็จะเล่นเกมคำถามกับคุยหินเหรอคะบอก
ว่าคิว and เองนะคะตอนนี้สมัคร
ไม่มีคิว and จีน
เป็น Choice
ก็จะหักว่า AB  BA หรือควีนอลิซาเบธจะ
เลือกอะไร
ค่ะ
คือคำถามข้อที่ 1 ผู้หญิงมีไหมคะถ้าไม่
ถึงมีสิแต่ผู้หญิงไม่มี Choice ให้เรื่อง
นะครูฟ้า
เค้าทำไมล่ะเราก็ก็ถ้าเราคุยก็คิดไงคะฟ้า
ถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยได้ไปเจอเจอกับคุยนาริท
เสด็จผู้หญิงก็ต้องอยากคุยใช่ไหมอยากคุย
แล้วก็อยากรู้จักควีนอลิซาเบธไง
อ่ะผู้หญิงจะคุยอะไรรู้หญิงก็จะมีคำถาม
แต่เพียงถามข้อเดียวเลยนะคะครูฟ้า
เนื้อหาอะไรอ่ะจะคุยก็จะถามก็ให้คล้ายครู
ฟ้านะแต่ว่าไม่มีสอยนะคะคุยก็จะถามว่าตอน
นี้เนาะ
20022 เนี่ยคุยนาลิซาเบ็ธเนี่ยเป็นควีน
ใช่ไหมคะคุณก็เลยจะถามว่าถ้า
ๆควีนอลิซาเบธเนี่ยไม่ได้เป็นควีนหรอกไม่
ได้เป็นคุยของอังกฤษเราอาจจะคุยอริสเบต
อาจจะมีพี่ชายใช่ไหมพี่ชายอันนี้พ่อ
แม่แล้วก็คนนี้เป็น King น้องคุยนาลิซา
เบ็ธเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้เป็นควีนถ้าคุยลาริส
เอ้อเบ็ดไม่ได้เป็นควีนแล้วควีนอลิซาเบธ
ในคิด
อยากทำงานอะไร
นะ
อยากเป็นคุณหมอสมัยคุณหมออ่ะเจ๊หมวยคุณ
หมอเวลาเราไม่สบายเราก็ไปหาคุณหมอแล้วคุณ
หมอก็ทำงานที่โรงพยาบาลปีบ่อยากเป็นคุณ
หมออยากเป็น
ตำรวจสวยอยากเป็นนักร้องเพราะอยากรู้ค่า
ควีนอลิซาเบธไม่ได้เป็นคุยอยากทำงานอะไร
อันนี้เป็นทองทางเขาที่คู่หญิงคิดว่าจะ
ถามคุยนาลิซาเบ็ธ 1 ข้อค่ะกดแล้วก็หมด
แล้วหรอผู้หญิงคุยนฤเบศอย่าทำงานอะไรตาย
คุยเนี่ยเป็นซุปเปอร์สตาร์ล่ะ
เหยเพราะว่าควีนอลิซาเบธใช่ไหมคะเป็นควีน
ตั้งแต่น่าจะอร่อยก็มาเล่าประวัติคิดที่
เสม็ดแล้วเราจะอายุประมาณ 25 ไว้
อ่าอ้าวแบบพี่ไม่แน่ใจนะแต่ว่าตั้งแต่
เด็กๆอ่ะเออก็เลยแบบอยากรู้ว่าแต่ถ้าไม่
ได้เป็นควีนเออชอบอะไรอยากทำอะไรไงก็ฝาก
มาตรก็คือฟ้ามีคำถามจะถามคุยนาลิซาเบ็ธ
อีกเหรอคะมีหากว่าจะถามครีนอาจจะเย็นๆว่า
จะถามถวิลแล้ว
ราชินีนี้คุยหรือราชินีอลิซาเบธ
มันจะถามคลีนว่าว่าถ้าควีนเนี่ย
เดินมาทางนี้นะค่ะควีนมาเอาไม่ได้เขียน
ภาษาไทยทำไมเนี่ยมากรุงเทพฯค่ะไม่ๆถ้า
ควีนมาประเทศไทย
หน้ามาประเทศไทย
ควีนจะไปที่ไหนในประเทศไทย
อยากไปเที่ยวที่ไหนอยู่ในประเทศไทยให้
ควีนอยากไปที่ไหนในประเทศไทยเออ
มาพัทยามา
กรุงเทพฯหรือว่าไปเชียงใหม่
ไปภูเก็ตให้ภูเก็ต
มากควีนอยากไปที่ไหนและควีนอยากกินอะไรเห
วินอยากกินอะไร
อยากกิน
อะไรในประเทศไทยใช่ไหมอยากกินอาหารอะไรใน
ประเทศไทยไงแล้วฟิล์มบอกไม่อยากมาไม่ได้
เสียนี้เป็นเราเราอยากคุยกับควีนไง
เราอยากคุยกับควีนใช่แล้วก็จะถามว่าคุย
เนี่ยชอบอากาศหนาวหรือว่าอากาศหัวร้อน
ชอบหนาวหรือชอบร้อนแต่ฟ้าว่าร้อนก่อนนะคะ
แต่ละสิ
ซองร้อน a ร้อน
ดี
เอา
อ้าคุยเนี่ยชอบอะไรร้อนหรือว่าหนาวเก๋
ช่วยฟ้าผู้หญิงคิดได้หนึ่งคำถาม
อะไรคะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอยากจะถามกูว่าเอา
ของฝากขึ้นไปหน่อยได้ไหมอ่ะได้ค่ะกูฟ้าจะ
เกิด
สวยเสร็จแล้วเราอยู่ครูหญิงอ่ะจะถามว่า
เอ่อ
the  scene อลิซาเบทใช่ไหมคะวินอลิซาเบท
เนี่ย
แต่งงานแต่งงานต่างแต่งงานนะคะอ่ะแล้วก็
ก็มีลูกเนี่ย 1  2
3 เขาแล้วก็ 4 สมัยมีลูก 4 คนผู้หญิงจะ
ถามว่าควีนอลิซาเบธเนี่ยนะคะ
รักเนาะรักลูกคนไหนวันที่ 1 คนที่สองคน
ที่ 3 คนที่ 4 รักคนไหนมากที่สุดอุ้ย
ทำไม
อ่ะอยากรู้ไงอ่ะรักคนที่ 1 หรือรักคนที่
สองพีทไม่รู้คนหนึ่งคนในสองนะหรือรักคน
ที่ 3 หรือรักวันที่ 4 ไม่แน่ใจว่าคนที่ 1
ผู้ชายหรือว่าคนที่ 2 ผู้หญิงนะอันเนี้ย
อันนี้คิดเองอยากรู้
นิถามชายดีมากค่ะคำถามที่ดีนะพี่กูบอกว่า
อยากรู้กันค่ะเออน้องอันนี้ก็เป็น 5 เรา
เนี่ยได้ไปดื่มช้าใช่ไหมกับคุยนาลิซาเบ็ธ
เนาะเราอยากจะคุยหรืออยากจะถามอะไรควีนนะ
คะชายนักเรียนหรอคะเรียนคลิปออกไหมว่านัก
เรียนจะถามอะไรควีนจ่ายหรือนักเรียนจะคุย
อะไรกับควีนแล้วก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะ
แต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยผู้หญิงกับครูฟ้าก็
ก็ไปดื่มชาก่อนนะคะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้านะคะสวัสดีค่ะ
ก็อาจ